[Music]
hi there and welcome to the next video
on contrast and i kind of went back and
forth on what i was going to show you
guys uh in this example
uh but i what i ended up landing on was
what you see right here um it's this uh
skull a cow skull contrasted black on
white
uh i thought about showing you a couple
other things but ultimately it came back
to this one because i wanted to keep
uh it simple for this week like i've you
know i want to just to show you like the
style frames i don't want to show you uh
motion this week i've been focused just
on the design side the the
you know the single image
and uh in future weeks we will get more
uh we will go back into contrast for
sure uh in fact there's contrast stuff
coming up very soon uh that's definitely
more involved
but for this example
i just want to show you how i created
this contrasting uh
style frame that you know it's very
simple but it's pretty cool at the same
time there's some interesting things
going on
in this image there's some
interesting texture in here
there's these
checkerboard patterns back here there's
some grit some grime going on
and then you know obviously the black
and white so
a lot of times as we saw in the examples
um
black and white contrast is very popular
um and you see it all the time you see
it where there's black versus white or
shifted this way or diagonal you know
whatever so i tried to kind of stay
in that realm for this example
um and i came up with this so
um let me show you how i did this um
fairly quickly
okay so we're going to jump back in to
the project and we're going to make a
new composition
and i made this 1080 by 1080 again
because i designed this for instagram
because it's going to go up on the
instagram page
uh frames per second doesn't matter but
1080 by 1080 and we'll call this
skull
o2
first i'm going to do is i'm going to
drag in my skull
layer
which
is right here it's called cow
and i'll scale it down
something like
so whoops
guys have the right tool selected there
i have the mask tool so there's our
school
you know we could make it larger
you know there's different ways you
could frame this and we are going to
talk about framing in future lessons so
as we move through these lessons
throughout the year
things will definitely get a little more
involved as i can show you more and more
aspects together
elements and principles in one single
project but for now i'm trying to keep
it
fairly straightforward and just focused
on what we are learning and building
upon what we've already learned so
it's definitely a challenge for me but
it's fun at the same time
so anyways let's
something like so
after we have the cow and the cows go in
a good position i'm going to go back to
my project i'm going to select the paper
i used and this is just a
piece of torn paper
that i brought into png with an alpha
channel as you can see here
and
i am going to
start
creating some contrast with this paper
the reason i'm actually designing inside
of after effects versus photoshop
is for one main reason for me which is i
have so many different plugins
third-party plugins inside of after
effects that once i get a good design
base
uh where i like it to be
i can easily apply
different effects that i see necessary
for that design right here in after
effects in the past
i've had to design a base in photoshop
bring that bass file into after effects
break it into layers and then start
applying my effects and years and years
ago i've you know just thought well why
don't i just do this all in after
effects why do i have to design in
photoshop and so i moved it over to to
after effects you know for 90 of the
time
now there are certain times when
you know i have to be in photoshop um to
cut out images um if it's very
detailed cutting out you know simple
cutouts i can use masks in after effects
great
but things like hair or just
certain things where i cut out i you
know start in photoshop bring that in to
after effects
and there's also a couple other plugins
i do have in photoshop that are not
available
uh in after effects which i wish they
were but they're not unfortunately so
uh but anyways 90 of the time i'm in
after effects designing so even if it's
a still image
okay so we've got the paper here and i'm
just going to rotate it
90 degrees
and
i am going to tell the cow to alpha
matte the paper
and there you go there's
the first part of our contrast the one
thing i immediately see is i don't love
how big this tear is right this tear of
paper if i turn the paper back on you
can see that now maybe it works for your
example but
for your design but i'm just going to
scale this down i want smaller i'll turn
it back off
you know maybe something
maybe even more 30
let's see what this looks like
yeah i like that
so that's the first
part of our design right so
you'll notice or you probably noticed
that it was black and white so
i'm just going to go to effect color
correction tent
and it's black and white right so now
i'm going to select paper cow hit
command d on the keyboard to duplicate
on this count i'm going to af out excuse
me i'm going to alpha invert the matte
so the bottom one was alpha matte
top one is alpha invert matte and
there's our other half of the image
right
this one has the tint applied i'm going
to reverse it so i just hit swap swap
colors
and there you go
so actually this is the reverse of the
other image i did uh but that's okay
actually we'll go ahead and
swap the bottom one so that's closer to
what i originally had
um so looking at this now i don't like
this section right here
with the tear so i'm gonna select both
pieces of
paper and just i don't know maybe
something like that
rotate
oh something i guess that's still 90
degrees
i'm just gonna drag them up
or down
okay it works for me
cool so next i'm going to do is
hmm
let's bring in the digital texture that
i used um which is this
is not that one it is
this puppy
so i uh came up with a search term a
while back uh which was zepto bars right
here i don't remember how i came up with
this word i've never heard of a zepto
bar before uh but i googled it and under
reuse for modification larger than four
megapixels i found several images i
liked this was one this is the one that
you saw here in after effects
but just really cool
zepto bars
something inside of a computer
so
really cool
i think this one's super cool as well
i'm going to do some more work with
these in the near future i've already
started a few other projects
with them that i'll show you in the
future so
so i'm going to turn this guy on i'm
going to scale them down
and just find something interesting
i don't know maybe
maybe that's good where it's at and i'm
going to duplicate the cowl
and
yeah that's really cool
[Music]
and i found that using the divide
transfer mode was pretty cool
after i made it black and white
now what i love about this
version i'm creating is that there's
most of the textures over here but
there's a little bit
over in here which is pretty cool
i'm also going to turn the transparency
down to 50 percent
and i'm going to go ahead and drop in a
new solid background and we'll call it
checkerboard
bring that down there and to this layer
i'm going to apply
believe it's generate
checkerboard
yeah
and all i did on this was i scaled it
way up
um i originally started with this with
the four squares
but for whatever reason it was really
bugging me so right so right now this is
bugging me so i'm gonna turn that off
um
all i did was i rotated
45 degrees
and i believe i scaled it up
yeah
you know there's all different ways you
could play around with this
um
that's kind of cool like that
turn that guy back on
[Music]
and i'm gonna play around the levels
here just a bit
color correction levels
so i like how it's looking but it's just
there's something
it's too
[Music]
it's too contrasty i think
which this is gonna make it more
contrasty which i don't want
that's not too bad though like that
that's kind of interesting i actually
kind of like that
let's play around a little bit more here
with the texture
mm-hmm i like that and then i used uh
grime
which is a texture pack i'm gonna be
giving to you guys again
uh last time we got grunge this one
we're gonna get grime
and we're gonna put this on
multiply i think
oh maybe up here towards the top and
what's cool this is a quicktime file but
i can just move through and find
a section of it i like
which
a little too much
i actually don't mind that um and then i
had another texture that i brought in
which is like this kind of stamped
uh feel to it
and for this guy
i set him to
overlay
let's try
you can see how it really this texture
alone is uh totally affecting you know
the dark side
of the skull and it completely changes
the look uh depending on what transfer
mode i'm in so what i'm doing is i'm
hitting shift minus or shift plus on my
mac keyboard and it's cycling through
you'll see it down here
it's cycling through them
i kind of like that
and then a lot of times what i'll do is
i'll just drag
uh
you know through the timeline just i'll
move uh elements up and down the
timeline just to see
if it affects things so that's with it
more towards the top off
on
above grime it doesn't work
go back to multiply
overlay
most of the time it's multiply overlay
or screen those are the three that i
always start with
because they give me the most um
you know different they give they give
me more uh variations um and then based
upon if i like like overlay then i'll
try some of those transfer modes right
there that are categorized with overlay
like soft light hard light linear if i
like multiply i'll try darken color burn
those kind of things so those are the
three i usually start with
i'm also going to like add a new uh
solid for the background
and make it just black
it should darken up
these checkerboards yeah so this is
without
and
this is width
so let's do this
[Music]
so that's
fairly interesting
[Music]
uh
uh something else i'm going to do is i'm
going to scale down
the grime
i'm actually going to rotate it 90
degrees
that's pretty cool
the one thing that's bugging me right
now is i'm just staring at this is the
texture the digital texture right here
and i think it's just because that image
isn't working for me anymore
that's interesting
so all i did here was just rotate the
texture
just to see
how i was looking there
let's go back to 100 opacity
and let's try screen
no
multiply
no
uh maybe difference
no
so i'll cycle through them
[Music]
again
[Music]
so that's uh really interesting to me
but obviously
it uh
covers everything up that we've already
done
so i could try and do is
drag that all below the original cow
image
and just make that cow image a transfer
mode of
see that's already interesting overlay
screen
multiply so ctrl z control z
um that's pretty cool
the paper
is too far to the right
so i selected both layers i'm nudging
them over with my keys
right now
and i am going to
readjust the texture again
yeah that's really cool actually i like
that it looks like it's got like this
kind of digital static
feel to the left side and a very organic
feel to the right side
so
that's what i wanted to show you today
there's no chromatic aberration um
there's no um
special plugins although we could do
something interesting just really
quickly
um you know how much i love the lighting
effect i love to use glow
let's see if so if i turn down the
threshold
we could try that
that's actually really cool
mess with the overall brightness
um you know with this glow there's so
many things you could do with you know
like the width
crank that slightly um
you know the side width
which i don't like that
the width y
it's
okay somewhere in there and then just
adjusting the um
widths of the red greens and blues will
really make a huge difference you see
there's purplish colors coming on this
is making everything more green as i
crank it up
if i mess with the reds
that's kind of interesting
i still like it more black and white but
with glow without with glow without
something one more thing i'll try as
well is a lot of times if i have a lot
of black in a design
i'll actually try uh lighting
glow darks
and what that does is it brings in this
this extra darkness i don't really know
how to explain it
um
you know the factual reason for what
it's doing
um but with
without with without you can see that it
just makes the blacks that much blacker
but it gives it like this black glow as
you can see
in here so
you can adjust the darkness
the threshold again
but i don't like it on this particular
version i do like the glow like i
typically always do
we could try maybe a little bit of a red
glow
just to see it's not going to work
the green is kind of interesting
i really like how it's highlighting this
side of the skull
more than that side
so that's kind of cool it's just a
little bit of a pinkish off-white
color and i'll crank up the brightness
just a tad there
there we go there is our contrasted
skull um looks really cool to me i'm
going to post this on instagram
leave me a comment let you know let me
know what you thought of this week's
material on contrast
your feedback is very important to me so
i know what to do for future lessons how
to keep rolling with it you know some of
these lessons are more simple some are
more advanced so i can try and mix it up
for all of you guys so
until uh next week i'm cameron and this
is stylecraft see ya